but i aspire to do far more than
that and devise something of
real power what is it you hope to craft
welcome back everyone it's charlie this will be my
full lord of the rings the rings of power episode
1 and episode 2 video there were a whole bunch
of easter eggs and references and i'll explain
what's going on with the timeline during these
events in the show because there's a bunch of
stuff that they speed run over but as the name
imply the rings of power the series is all about
during the second age when sauron created the
actual rings of power and the one ring of power
one ring to rule them all so be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes there's
going to be eight episodes total during season
one and i believe part of the deal that amazon
had to sign to get the rights to actually do this
show required them to do like up to five seasons
so i'm pretty sure that unless something really
weird goes on they will definitely do season two
they spent about a half a billion dollars just to
get season one out the door but they had to spend
about half of that money just to get the rights so
really they only spent about 250 million dollars
on season one but careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet we'll just
start at the beginning and work our way through
scene by scene talking about easter eggs wtf
moments and like the really important stuff the
title of episode 1 is called a shadow of the past
it's a reference to a bunch of different things
mostly morgoth and sauron in the war of wrath in
the present day of the show it's a couple years
after the war of wrath has ended sauron becomes
the quote-unquote shadow that they mention a
couple times through the first two episodes
the metaphorical and the literal shadow from the
past war threatening to gain strength and start
a new war like the war of the ring the war of the
last alliance like i said the present day of the
show is mostly during the second age the second
age only lasted for like a little over 3 400 years
everything before that like the first stage the
year of the trees the pre-history that's closer
to like 20 000 years so when i say they speed run
through like the first 20 000 years of history or
so yeah they really did speedrun i think that's
for a couple different reasons one because they're
just using it as a prologue meant to be a mirror
for the prologue and fellowship of the ring like
even though they obviously have a new version
of galadriel playing the character it's also
galadriel doing the narration of the prologue
just like she did during fellowship of the ring
in the prologue itself is very similar to the
prologue to fellowship of the ring like it covers
the last major war like the last major conflict in
what happens right after that the war they cover
in fellowship with the ring in the prologue is the
war of the last alliance the third age begins like
right after sauron is defeated at the beginning of
this show the first stage ends right after morgoth
is defeated so when we're meeting the little girl
version of galadriel here she's less than 100
years old she was about 138 years old when the
two trees were destroyed when she says nothing
is evil in the beginning that's a reference to
morgoth himself because he wasn't created by a
louvitar as an evil being the cosmic hierarchy of
power within the lord of the rings universe works
like this so up at the top you have the one true
god of the universe that's a louvitar beneath him
are the valar those are like the lesser gods but
they're still gods morgoth was the most powerful
of all those gods beneath their pantheon or the
lesser powerful may are they're more like angels
still super powerful cosmic beings but not nearly
as powerful as the valar sauron and gandalf for
instance are both part of the mayar but they're
part of different sub-branches of those groups of
angels when you see the characters walking around
on middle-earth throughout the events of the
movies obviously the tv show now they're basically
like cosmic beings trapped in human form it's sort
of like the star wars reference like when you
become a force ghost you become way more powerful
they're way more powerful in their true cosmic
forms so like when sauron and gandalf are walking
around on middle earth they're like special
cosmic rules that prevent them from using
their full power so what you see them using during
the movies is like a fraction of their true power
and what galadriel is narrating here is basically
morgoth turning evil because of his pride and
eventually seeking to rule over the world and
that leading to the destruction of the trees
the war of the wrath or the war of the jewels as
they call it because it's the war of the silmarils
a lot of that is covered during the events of the
silmarillion the main events of this series during
the second age is more about what sauron does
after all that trying his own more subversive plan
for taking over the world using the rings of power
they kind of brush over this during galadriel's
prologue here but sauron starts out as sort of
like the chief lieutenant of one of the other
greater gods serving morgoth so sauron started out
being like the underling's underling in a cosmic
sense like he wasn't even that close to morgoth
even though during the events of the movies they
make him seem like this really crazy cosmic big
bad morgoth his ultimate master was way way more
powerful but when galadriel says there hadn't been
a sunrise yet that's actually meant to be taken
literally because originally all the light
on the continent here like when you see her
running around in the field with their friends
here and there's light shining down on them
that's not coming from the sun the light is coming
from the two trees those trees provided light for
the entire continent of valinor here it wasn't
until morgoth and his servant the great spider
angolian the ancestor of shella the giant spider
destroyed the trees and then the remnants of the
trees became the moon and the sun and then you
have the first actual sunrise so just to give you
an idea for how old galadriel is during the events
of the lord of the rings movies she's over 8 000
years old when the events of this series pick up
in present day she's closer to like a thousand
years old in the actual first episode when they
pick up in the waste with them on their mission
is a couple hundred years after the start of
the second age really cool side detail too
when you see the two trees being destroyed by
morgoth you see his shadow rise above them they
were actually able to use some of the remnants of
those trees to seed saplings that became like the
white tree of gondor in the other white trees
that we'll see like there's one on numenor too
the whole scene of the boat in the water is just
meant to give you an idea for what her personality
is like and this is one of the big changes i think
from the books as most people know them so far
is that galadriel in this series is way stabbier
way more aggressive than the book version is being
portrayed then we meet her brother finrod who
she was really close to it's his death at the
hands of sauron and morgoth's men that drives her
to find sauron during the events of the series and
try to kill him they only show a montage of the
war and his death but he was captured by sauron's
men later and in his dungeons that's how he died
it was a really death in the episode they show
sauron's magical brand on his body i don't recall
seeing the brand in the lord of the rings lore
before this so they might have created it for the
show but essentially it's exactly what galadriel
says it is during the episode even though they
claim that their elvin smiths have no idea what
it is nobody can decode this i think the whole
idea here is that it's meant to be a magical rune
that serves a couple different purposes like it
looks really wicked it just freaks people out in
general because it's magical orcs and servants
of sauron can also use it to follow his trail
he can also direct his armies and leave secret
messages for them to decode and also i believe
the mark itself because it has a special magical
brand and it's tied to this dark altar in the
place that we see during the prologue with all
those orcs melted into the wall using dark magic
i think the whole idea with the mark is that it
becomes a precursor to what the rings of power
will eventually become the way that sauron binds
his power to the many lesser rings to the one ring
of power like all the rings contain a piece of his
essence which is why he's able to control all them
through the one ring this is where we get to the
special sword the theo finds with the brand on it
that responds to his blood the mark itself looks
exactly like the mark on the sword hilt so the
early theory is that this mark of sauron will be
something that sauron bakes into the creation of
the rings of power and is sort of like a magical
slave system that binds everything to himself also
i have some other theories about what's going on
with the sword and with the hal brand character
because the symbol on the necklace that hal brand
is wearing is from the same village that bronwyn
is from and how bran says that he is from the
southlands which is where bronwyn and theo are
from so the other biggest thing on the show is
the whole mystery of who is sauron in disguise
during this part of the timeline all we know from
the books is that he disguised himself in the form
of an elf named himself anatar and pretended to
be friends to the elves instead that he brought
them these gifts from the gods he was going to
help them and that's how he was able to deceive
keller brimbore into creating the rings of power
now keller brimbore himself didn't create all the
rings of power himself he just created the elven
rings other people working with him created the
other rings of power but like during episode 2
you see keller brimbore showing elrond his plans
for the most powerful forge ever created in middle
earth the forge that they'll eventually probably
use to create the rings of power my early theory
right now though is that they'll end season one
with the creation or beginning the creation of the
actual forge like they're going to get help from
the dwarves and it's already the end of episode
two and the dwarves have not completely agreed
to help them create it yet so the whole idea is
that they actually probably won't make the real
rings of power to like season three season four
like however many seasons the show runs in all
that time we'll just be playing this guessing game
who is sauron but i do have some theories you all
probably have some theories too after watching the
first couple of episodes you can definitely tell
that amazon has changed some of the story for the
character just so you don't immediately recognize
who sauron's going to be but the whole reason why
it was rings that sauron used to try and take over
the world was because that was his specialty
making magical items like that his master that
he studied under that he served was called allowed
he was also called the smith literally the god of
forging things so that's why sauron was an expert
at crafting magical items like the rings of power
and that's why he would try to deceive keller
brimbore because he is like the greatest craftsman
of the elves the greatest craftsman in the land
the only big surprise here during the prologue
is that you don't actually see morgoth himself
you just see his shadow above the two trees here
i'll talk a little bit more about the oath of
feyenoord when i talk about elrond when he shows
up later in the episode but the whole idea is
that the war of wrath was literally called the
war of the jewels because it was a war over
the silmarils themselves they were actually
crafted by feanor to contain some of the essence
of the two trees that morgoth destroyed so they
just had this incredible amount of cosmic
power that he used to enhance his own power
we see all the elven ships sailing to war this
is them leaving the continent of valinor and
going to middle-earth as the map shows i do love
the way they do transitions in this with the map
this is happening on this part of the continent
belaria where the elves lived after they came to
middle earth and you have to keep in mind that
this is a crazy speed run version of the plot
because hundreds of years have gone by between
the time that they sailed and when this actual
battle is happening when her brother is getting
ready to fall but what happened here is that the
other gods themselves got involved in the war
and there was so much power running around in
this part of middle earth that the collateral
damage from all their battles literally sank
the part of the continent underneath the ocean
which is also a bit foreshadowing for numenor
a big part of the series will be covering the
downfall of numenor but we really won't see a lot
of numenor stuff till episode 3 it seems like the
only bummer here is that they don't actually show
you what they did to morgoth after they defeated
him because he was literally like the most
powerful god next to the one true god a louvitar
they couldn't actually kill him the only way that
they could stop him was to permanently trap him in
this void-like abyss outside of creation so like
all the way during the events of the movies later
in the timeline during the fourth age there's all
these prophecies about his eventual return like
darkness will return because he's still alive he's
just kind of chilling out there in the middle of
nothingness but the final act that they show you
in the prologue is the younger sauron on screen
in his familiar suit of armor that you see him
fighting in during the war the last alliance and
if you couldn't tell this area where they show
him is the same place in the frozen north that
galadriel's squad visits later in the episode
hundreds and hundreds of years later galadriel
explains how her brother was captured and by him
and that's why they try to make it so personal for
her his dagger that she carries with her for all
these hundreds of years will be important again in
a second when i start talking about hal brand too
more clues and easter eggs on our path to finding
out who the secret sauron is on the show is sort
of like game of thrones and finding out who the
secret targaryens are when her voice over kind
of fades out and they step into the present day
of the show then climbing up the cliff face here
a lot of her dialogue sounds very similar to
the dialogue during the fellowship of the ring
prologue when she's talking about how people
just over time because of their short life spans
just forgot about the war the last alliance in the
ring of power until smeagol found it in the river
more and more of our kind began to believe
that sauron was but a memory and some things
that should not have been forgotten were lost so
it's the same idea at the beginning of the main
events of this series where like most people just
don't have the long life spans that elves have
and have forgotten about the war of wrath morgoth
and sauron in general so that i really worried
about him much to their misfortune when they find
the altar with sauron's magical sigil on it the
orc fused to the wall like i said galadriel
says some dark magic was being worked here
by sauron the magic was probably him working on a
spell to change his appearance disguised himself
it's also probably connected to the special
sword that theo finds in the southlands where
hal bran says he came from and if it was hidden
in his house maybe he is secretly hal bran's son
because theo says he has no idea what happened to
his father even though his mother is in love with
the elf iran deer there's a lot of theories
i have now about what's going on with theo
mystery dad not sure who he is finds what looks
like sauron sword with his special sigil on it
that activates when it tastes some blood a lot of
theories about whether or not sauron could ever
potentially have any illegitimate children there
aren't any children of his in the books that they
ever speak of but it is possible for mayor to have
children with mortals and other people on earth
because one of the parents of luthien of the
famous baron and luthien one of elron's ancestors
was a mayar but like i said i think the whole
idea with the sigil is that it's sort of like
a precursor to what he'll bake into the rings of
power sort of like a horcrux type of magical sigil
when she says that they were meddling with the
powers of the unseen world that's the wraith
world that you see when frodo and bilbo put the
ring of power on it's like a pure magical realm
they have the snowtrow battle just showing
you some of galadriel's skills with weapons
she'll have more fight scenes in future episodes
some of them more playful than others her officers
betray her wanting to go back to linden putting
down their swords and you get a big swell up of
this really cool music score all the music for
the series is being done by bear mccreary who
most of you will probably remember from battlestar
galactica or something else recently he's done a
bunch of really cool stuff then they reveal the
har foots and they're meant to be kind of like
the show's version of hobbits so hard foots are
not characters from the books like they invented
them for the tv show because the first hobbits
didn't appear on middle earth until the third age
the main character here sort of like the frodo
of the series is meant to be nori she's the
one that eventually finds the meteor man lots of
early theories about what's going on with him he
looks very much kind of like gandalf but gandalf
didn't come to middle earth until the third age
so obviously he's probably some other type of
wizard maybe one of the blue wizards and when
he's trying to tell nori who he is where he comes
from he uses his magic to create the image of one
of the constellations in the sky whispering to
fireflies like gandalf whispered to birds he was
speaking quenya the language of the elves and i
think he was trying to tell her that he literally
fell from the heavens like he crashed down from
the heavens like pointing up at the constellations
and was sent to middle earth to help everyone the
same way that gandalf was eventually sent to earth
it also seems like he's full of magical power
like the fire responds to him when he sits up
and then sits back down the only thing i think
is a misdirect here though because everyone's
kind of wondering who is sauron going to be who is
meteor man going to be when they zoom out on the
picture of his crash site it looks kind of like
the flaming eye of sauron i think that's meant to
be a misdirect like meteor man is not meant to be
sauron then we see elrond for the first time the
actor you may recognize he's the same person who
played young ned stark on game of thrones during
the events of this series at this point in the
timeline elrond is more of a diplomat within their
hierarchy in linden which is why he's the one
to go treat with the doors because he's got this
pre-existing relationship that goes back to the
war of wrath there are a bunch of different groups
of elves around middle earth and just around the
world in general so the high elves are the noldor
here that gil galad rules over so just because he
is the high king of the noldor doesn't mean that
he rules over every single elf so for example iran
deer comes from the cindar elves that's the group
of elves that legolas and his father come from
like his father has been their king for a long
long time they descend from a completely different
line than galadriel and the noldor descend from
so for example gil gallad and keller brimbour
are both galadriel's cousins and for example
their grandfather fenway was actually the ruler
of this city here where the two trees are that
you see during the prologue it's called tyrion
it still exists there but it's on a completely
different continent you have to remember galadriel
basically came to middle earth during the start of
the first stage and for example elrond wasn't born
till later till after all the elves had come to
middle earth in beleriad here so he has never been
to valinor until the end of return of the king
when they all depart the grey havens to go back
to the undying lands which is on valinor there's
a quick scene with the harfoots where nori's
mother references following the trail i think
because they're meant to be the ancestors of the
hobbits that's meant to be a reference to the
actual hobbit story because in that story there's
this whole tale about bilbo and the dwarves
leaving the path in merkwood which is where they
run into the spiders and things go off the rails
we see gilgalad give galadriel soldiers the honor
of going back to valinor which she obviously bails
on at the end of the episode and when elrond
tells her her chance to go there might not come
again that's obviously a reference to the end of
return of the king when she goes there again you
also have to remember during this conversation
when they're looking at the mural here that is
literally like the passage that you see them
undertaking at the end of the episode elrond
is treating it like such a huge deal because he's
never been there he's only heard about this place
then we meet the southlanders so southlanders
are just what they called regular humans who
lived in middle earth this whole time and were not
numenoreans like regular people without special
god-given longer lifespans like the numenoreans
they set up this very barren and luthien aragorn
and arwen type of relationship story with iran
deer in bronwyn what's been going on in this area
of the world since the war of wrath had ended
is that the elves just in general like all
elves all groups of elves have been watching
over the southlanders race to make sure that
they don't do anything bad again because during
the war of wrath they're race sided with morgoth
like i said the iran deer himself and his group of
elves in the tower here are from the sylvan elves
which is the same group of elves that legolas
comes from completely different group of bells
than the high elves that we saw in linden but
that's why you see irandir's armor look like it's
carved out of the wood like that just because each
group of elves has their own unique style to them
all of a render's talk here about the past and
evil being within them whether they like it or
not being still with them is foreshadowing for
sauron's sword that theo finds like evil is
literally and metaphorically still with them also
you have all the orcs that are tunneling beneath
their villages trying to steal them all three of
these characters though irandir bronwyn and theo
are brand new characters they created for the
show which is why i think they have all these
twists with the special sword and with hal
brand who's also not from the books as well
want to keep us guessing about what's really
going on with sauron during the series
because of their relationship i kind of wondered
if theo might secretly be a rendeer's son and they
just kept it on the dl this whole time but there's
a couple different things that could be going on
with the character he could actually be hal bran's
son or he himself could just be like a young
version of sauron who's changed himself to look
like that when the sword looks like that i think
the whole idea with the restoration of the sword
the blood sauron symbol his essence has something
to do with sauron returning in true form but right
now i'm still leaning towards the idea that it
might be how brand is the secret sauron and once
he gets the sword back and the sword is restored
then he'll achieve way more power but not quite as
much power as when he's actually got the one ring
of power the whole idea with the orcs trying to
steal all these people i think it's just the idea
that evil is slowly growing in this area because
you also have to imagine that even though sauron
hasn't gotten even close to creating the rings of
power yet over the many many hundreds thousands
of years there were all kinds of different
wards with orcs along the way like lesser wars
so there will be big battles on the show that
don't have anything to do with sauron himself
yet the whole idea right now is that sauron has
been trying to hide out for the last hundred years
but i think the whole idea with this sword the
sigil binding his power to the sword itself and
these other marks is sort of like his prototype
for working on the rings of power in the way
that the rings work and when you look at the
descriptions of sauron during this period in
the books they say that he appeared to everyone
as a friend claiming to help them in creating
the rings of power hal brand literally winds up
saving galadriel's life using the very dagger that
she wants to use to kill him eventually and it
was on her brother's body when he was and killed
by sauron there's this weird chemistry between the
two of them so it seems like she kind of hates him
right now but she'll eventually grow to like him
like something a little bit spicy is going on here
that just feels like something that sauron would
try to do some trick he would try to pull the
whole idea is that it's supposed to be the person
you least expect like the nicest person ever oh he
could never be sauron he just saved my life i'd be
dead if it weren't for him and when you actually
look at sauron's true form this is actually
deleted scene from return of the king but this
is what sauron looks like in his original angelic
form he's supposed to be this really beautiful
looking angel so i think the whole idea is that
they wanted to cast an attractive looking person
as sauron and someone you wouldn't suspect which
is also why they changed some of the book plot
behind what his name is and what he makes himself
look like so that all the book readers won't just
point and be like oh it's the guy anatar right
there because that's his name in the books you
can all let me know in the comments though like
who do you think is sauron after the first couple
of episodes who is he pretending to be remember
he's supposed to wash up looking like a friend and
he's also supposed to deceive the new minorians
leading them to eventually invade valinor inviting
the destruction from a louvitar and in this
episode hal bran literally washes up on numenor
also when the sea serpent is attacking all their
people hal brand is with those others their you'll
ask them later how come you didn't care about any
of the people you're with and he just talks about
surviving that also feels kind of like a sauron
thing to do like i don't really care about any of
those other people i just want to survive myself
but then they obviously end the episode with the
meteor man crashing to earth i'll kind of explain
what i think is going on with this character and
how there's a misdirect with the very eye of
sauron looking fire ring around him episode
two is titled adrift that's just a reference to
galadriel's adventure at sea with hal brand being
rescued by the numenoreans they also debut the new
intro scene it starts with the shapes of the two
trees and basically like all the shifting shapes
here are meant to retell the prologue story like
the story of the show in general the timeline that
you got during episode one that's why at the end
here it shifts into the shape of the ring like the
one ring of power because the show is all about
the creation of the rings of power elrond goes
to oregon to meet keller brimbore and he tells
him about his plan to create the greatest forge
in the history of the world like i said they'll
probably use the force to create the actual rings
of power in the myth role that the dwarves had
found at the end of the episode like the mithril
itself will be the substance they used to shape
into the actual rings we get a really cool really
quick history lesson when elrond sees feyenoord's
hammer talking about the history of the silmarils
how he created them how they led to the war of
wrath what happened with morgoth when keller
brimbour says true creation requires sacrifice
that's also a reference to sauron creating the one
ring of power because he pours so much of himself
literally and metaphorically into the actual
ring like he poured his life force into the ring
which is also why you can't truly kill him unless
you destroy the ring pretty much everything that
comes out of kell brimboard's mouth here is
meant to be foreshadowing for the creation of
the rings of power themselves how he feels about
his life's work creating something of true power
sauron in disguise ultimately trying to use his
own pride against him then we get to see kaza doom
in its prime for the first time on the show but
remember by the time of the movies in the third
age the balrog had already taken over this area
the armies the orcs had moved in killed all the
dwarves that had remained we did actually see
a version of the balrog during the trailer so
we'll see when it actually shows up i don't know
which episode they're going to feature it in but
the whole thing with elrond invoking the contest
to gain the audience with durin is just to sort
of brush over a lot of the history between the two
of them because as duran says he is super pissed
off at him for missing most of his major life
events because even though dwarves do have longer
lifespans than normal humans it's still like the
blink of an eye to an elf his wife desa here is a
totally new character they've created for the show
i don't know how big of a character she's gonna be
then when we jump back to galadriel and hal brand
she asked him about his necklace like i said it's
got the same symbol on it of the village that
bronwyn and theo come from in the southlands
so i think that hal brand is connected to sauron's
sword which is one of the reasons why i think that
hal brand is sauron in disguise because he's
been so helpful saving galadriel's life kind
of forming that bond between the two of them so
that when there's like a reveal of him really
being sauron in later episodes potentially if
it really is hal brand it'll be this way bigger
wtf payoff because if galadriel starts to have
feelings for him wouldn't that be a much bigger
twist she actually finds herself caring about the
very person that she's sworn her life to destroy
it could be a misdirect could be someone else but
right now just hal bran seems like the strongest
candidate you can also let me know in the comments
though because of the connection to sauron's sword
here do you think that theo is either hal brand's
son or do you think he's secretly a ron dear son
but they end episode 2 with them seemingly rescued
by what i think is going to wind up being isildur
during the prologue of the fellowship of the ring
the war of the last alliance he's the prince of
gondor that winds up defeating sauron and taking
the one ring of power with the shard of narcill
but at this point earlier in the timeline before
the destruction of numenor he and his father are
still living on numenor so we'll get like the
deep dive into numenor when we visit the island
in episode 3 next week the way they depict numenor
in the world of lord of the rings is kind of like
an atlantis type of advanced culture because they
have extended lives like they just have way better
seafaring technology just all of their technology
in general is way better but a silver is basically
like aragorn's great great grandfather many
times removed so lots of connections to what
happens during the events of the lord of the
rings movies obviously a lot of history that
they cover in the silmarillion if there's any
really big easter eggs or wtf moments during
the episodes that i didn't talk about during the
video just write them below in the comments or
if you have big questions about what's going on
with the characters there's so much stuff that
they cover in these first couple of episodes you
could do like an entire hour-long video just about
the prologue itself because there's just so much
history that they cover in such a short time span
but my full episode 3 video will post next week
there's going to be eight episodes total like
i said so make sure you enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss that my full house
of the dragon episode 3 video will post sunday
too everyone click here for my fufll house the
dragon episode 3 trailer video and click here
for my full house of the dragon episode 2 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one
you